but Halloween isn't just for kids of
course especially from the 1970s and
1980s with a growing interest in things
like horror movies and what is sometimes
referred to as Monster culture the
classic monster movies of the 1930s and
40s such as Dracula Frankenstein and the
mummy and the Wolfman became associated
with Halloween and incorporated into
that aesthetic Halloween had always been
a night when the kids could you know for
one night of the year stay up late and
do things that were a little more
mischievous than on regular days and out
of forbidden excitement in a certain way
and the holiday kind of took on a
similar role as it became more popular
with adults too it was a time of
celebrating and indulging in dark
culture in horror and in the maab